[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Sarah Jamie and welcome to in
this together the podcast that brings
you the good news stories of the week
because we all need a bit of that right
now what we need inspirational tales
from around the globe the lighter
moments and the local heroes doing
fantastic things to help others in the
face of coronavirus coming up sat boy
slim heaps preys on the NHS and tells us
his plans to celebrate with them at the
end of this crisis and I just thought
I'd invite all the NHS workers and the
blue light workers anyone on the
frontline really cheering people up
through music or making them feel
connected through music is the one thing
I can do living through history
seeing the coronavirus through a child's
eyes coronavirus you're a funny old
thing
are you a blessing in disguise and have
to still have your big day on lockdown
we meet the Manchester police officers
who took a break from the beat to say I
do all that more on the way including
your good news thanks for getting in
touch on social media at Sky sarah-jane
hashtag in this together and email in
this together at SkyDome UK well let's
start with some good news the government
has announced a covert 19 vaccine with
an 80% success rate should be available
very soon health secretary Matt Hancock
has said 14 million pounds is going to
go towards helping the efforts an Oxford
University and Imperial College London
here's our political correspondent Kate
McCann with more some hopes there on
getting a vaccine there why is that
important well it's crucial for helping
those who are currently shielded the
over 70s those with ongoing health
conditions to get back into normal life
until there's a vaccine they remain very
in very difficult circumstances trying
to avoid catching Cove in 19 the speed
that this team have worked this joint
effort to try and come up with a vaccine
is really quite something well the
trials have already started and the
Jenner Institute team at Oxford want
around a million doses to be sent out by
September we'll keep you up to date on
their progress of course on Sky News
join me this week to look at the
brighter side of things GP doctor Zoe
Williams who you'll have seen on your TV
screens throughout this crisis offering
medical advice and support and she's
been through the mill herself she wasn't
very well at the start of this lockdown
she joins us now Zoe how are you doing
yeah it was right at the beginning so
over a month ago now that I've got
symptoms which I'm not hundred percent
certain but 99.9% certain work obeys
yet really wipe me out for a couple of
weeks but I've now made a full recovery
and isn't good again working out back
working yeah yeah I mean you're back at
work on the front line a really busy
time what's that been like well it's
really bizarre
because in general practice we are doing
our work differently so most of our work
is now on the phones telephone
consultations and we do see the
occasional patient if necessary but
strangely it's been rather quiet and
that's really concerning for us as GPS
because I think sometimes patients
either think we're not open we very much
are or they don't want to bother us
because there's so much going on which
would you want you to bother us and all
they're worried about coming to the
practice in case they pick something up
so it's really important the people out
there know that GP practices are open
you'll get a telephone consultation
rather than face-to-face but we will see
you if we need to examine you as well
yeah it's really important to let people
know if they're feeling ill it might not
necessarily be coronavirus related but
they should still talk to their GP about
it that's a really important point to
make Zoe and what's team spirit like
because I saw this week you take part in
a project that went viral the you clap
for me now poem and it's really
interesting because the NHS at the
moment is the embodiment of in this
together yeah I mean that whole you clap
for me now things just came about so
quickly I was contacted by a lady called
Cecchini
over the weekend last weekend and then
she sent me the poem on Monday morning I
was in clinic just recorded a few bits I
read the poem and it just gave me
goosebumps because I think we're in this
period at the moment where people are
time king keen workers for the
incredible job that they're doing
irrespective of their color their Creed
which country they come from all that's
just become irrelevant and people are
just so grateful to the great job that
those people are doing and I think this
poem is really just asking people asking
everybody to continue that gratitude and
fans once we get through this and you
know not judge a person for their
ethnicity or their Creed or where
they've come from but judge them on the
value of who they are
and the contribution that they made yes
zoiy is a mixture of a lot of different
faces talking about the positive impact
of immigration on the NHS and the other
vital services that are quite frankly
keeping this country going right now
let's have a listen to some of it not
some foreign invader intro life-saving
don't see it go home don't say not him
you know how it feels for her to be a
prison you know how it feels to live in
fear
so you clap for me now all this love you
are bringing but don't forget when it's
no longer quiet it's such a powerful
message Zoe and I know what you mean by
it giving you goosebumps do you think
when we come out of this attitudes will
change towards immigration and the fact
that you know so many different people
with different backgrounds different
ethnicities different life stories keep
this country going now I really hope so
because I think we're in the midst of a
crisis at the moment and everybody's
coming together to fight against this
tiny little virus you know a virus is
not even equivalent to a single cell of
our body it's a little bit of genetic
material with the first protein spikes
stuck on it and it's completely ravaging
the whole world and I think in times
like this we see ourselves we're all one
species it doesn't matter where we're
from or where we came from where one
species and we're all clinging to each
other and coming together to fight this
thing and I just really hope that one of
the positives that will come out of this
at the other end is that those
prejudices that have been you know in
society too so long people will realize
that how just how pointless those
prejudices are it's a really powerful
poem in its online and you can see more
about it on the video version of this
podcast you could also find more about
it on Sky News com
I want to talk to you about PPE Zoe
still very much in the headlines
personal protection equipment still so
much controversy over the lack of
availability of PPE for frontline NHS
staff but what's interesting is well
government try and figure it out people
are stepping up and stepping in tell me
a bit about what's been going on yeah so
I mean it's week on week isn't it you
think gosh when is this gonna get sorted
because I do believe that the government
are doing everything that they can
unfortunately everything that they can
is just not enough so yeah so local
businesses colleges schools are stepping
up to provide PPE and in my own practice
we as GPS when we are seeing patients we
just weather the apron the gloves
the mask the surgical masks and we
should wear the visors or a detection
and we didn't have the eye protection so
Dilek our local college and they got
into other students and their to their
staff and their design technology
Department have gone into mass
production with 3d printers producing
visors just drop them off with a big
smile in his face and so to let us know
who else needs it's just brilliant it's
amazing yeah it's amazing isn't it there
are organizations like scrub hub where
people who are tailors or seamstresses
are getting their hands on it and making
scrubs I saw denise Van Outen pop up on
my Instagram account the other day she's
part of an effort in Essex where
interior designers who normally make
curtains and blinds are sending out
patterns to people in their home and
materials so they can make scrubs for
the NHS and I did really interesting
interview on Sky News last week Zoe with
a woman called Jasmine Howe who is part
of the meds supply drive UK you can get
in touch them on twitter at med sub
drive UK and basically they're asking
different industries and different
individuals to donate any PPE that they
have around because she said places like
catering facilities nail salons
tattooist so these organizations have
got equipment there that they can't use
at the moment that they can donate yeah
if you're listening to this and think
hang on a second I've got some PPE
equipment I'd like to donate on Twitter
at med sup Drive UK get in touch with
jasmine and her team and now Zoe last
week on the podcast we were talking
about the power of music during times
like this and I know you like your music
and the NHS such a talented bunch in so
many ways I don't
seen this this is the choir skies and
Sir Thomas's Hospital in London they've
covered a Mariah Carey classic to raise
money for NHS charities let's have a
listen
[Music]
with a choir with that absolutely
fantastic rendition Zoey is really taken
off so much support they're raising so
much money what did you make of it I
thought it was amazing I mean he put all
the back together when you've got them
all in the same shot I mean [ __ ]
genius but don't if you saw that Mariah
Carey herself actually posted on Twitter
she saw it instead that it brought tears
to her I mean she was like speaking of
DNA chants from America yeah that's
brilliant it's like music royalty the
music royal seal of approval from Mariah
Carey in voluntee runs the choir
actually said it's wonderful that the
only is the choir but so much positivity
for others but actually don't forget to
underestimate what it does for the choir
members they meet every week virtually
now of course they do it all online and
it really provides some stress relief
for them and a sense of community and
Zoe you work on the front line in the
NHS and you must know better than anyone
how important it is right now to switch
off and destress is vital to keep you
going right yes a bit of a release and I
think I've been quite surprised how many
of my friends and colleagues who were
doctors the nurses and health care
professionals are so talented
oh all we talked about it's so
fascinating okay dr. Zoe thanks for now
you're gonna be back in a short while to
spread some of the good news that's been
sent to us by Sky News users get
involved the email addresses in this
together at sky dot uk'
well I'm very excited to introduce our
next guest who has been the soundtrack
to our nights out for the past three
decades you know remember when we used
to go out to festivals clubs remember
that well he's now the soundtrack to our
kitchen discos he is superstar DJ Fat
Boy slim and he is promising the party
to end all parties for NHS staff when
this crisis is over
Norman cook is on lockdown in Brighton
and joins us now nan how are you I'm
good how you doing yeah really good
actually keeping positive it's a bit of
an odd time at the moment isn't it
it's a very
change time it's I mean is it wrong to
say that sometimes I'm almost excited by
it
are we going through something I did
that that word unprecedented has been
way overused but nice it's something you
kind of feel like we're making history
here which which is a good it's a good
way of spinning it so it feels like you
know we've got to get through this you
know our parents might went through the
Blitz and and this is kind of our blitz
so I see yeah occasionally I do find
some excitement in having to make do and
the way we have to live our lives has
not been treated because you lived a
jet-set lifestyle
until this coronavirus hit traveling the
world doing huge gigs and I'm just
wondering how you're finding a slightly
slower pace of life it's treating me
fairly so far I'm lucky that I live on
the beach so we've got fresh air and
feel like we've got some sense of space
and I'm locked down with people that I
love very dearly so that helps it's I
mean it's weird for me my obviously my
job involves the whatever the polar
opposite of social distancing is so that
was the first casualty and I cut before
we'd even lock down obviously I'd
already got my head around the fact that
I probably wouldn't be working much this
summer which is yeah which again it's
it's just for those things you have to
deal with yeah it's interesting isn't it
because I said your job is bringing
people together you know crowded dance
floors big gigs and I know you've spoke
in the past about the community you find
on a dance floor you know it doesn't
matter where you come from you know what
you think about things music is the
great leveler and when you all love the
same tune you're all in it together yes
I mean there's a tremendous sense of
community that comes through being
together listening to music and losing
yourself in a night owl but there's also
a power of music to have a sense of
community for the new community that
they sort of online community that we're
living through so we found other ways of
using what I do
to bring people together or give them
just giving a sense of less isolation
the fact that everybody's going through
the same thing and they're all still and
they're in their kitchen trying to get
excited on a Friday night too so I don't
know I mean my my in desperate times
like this you kind of view look to a
sense of the community of what can I
contribute to it and obviously my skills
of my skill set is fairly limited in
terms of what real good I can do for the
for the country or for for Humanity but
suppose cheering people up through music
or making them feel connected through
music it's the one thing I can do yeah
talk to me about this free party you're
putting on for NHS workers and their
partners as well I noticed that you like
you know they partners support them in
what they're doing so they deserve a big
night out as well it was just a friend
of mine who works at the NHS said oh
would you mind just doing a little
little viral for the NHS workers just
it's give them support or thanks or this
is quite early on so I made a little er
I made a little film hello this is a
message from Fat Boy slim to all the
doctors all the nurses all the key
workers and at the end of it I sort of
half jokingly said and when all this is
over we should have a big party together
and you know when we can and so many
people a they certainly took me up on
that and everybody I'm bump into the
supermarket goes brinjal party having
then and so I just thought it's the one
thing that I can be thinking about and
planning and doing and so we are booked
tonight at the Brighton Centre and we
just yeah and I just thought I'd invite
all the NHS workers and the blue light
workers anyone on the front line really
to come and you know shake off the
cobwebs when all this is over yeah and
they're certainly looking forward to
that tickets sold out in three minutes
and no I don't know if you know any
medics personally but boy do they know
how to party I was at Union with quite a
few they know how to let her hair down I
was actually married to a nurse at one
point in my life so yeah I'm aware of it
yes no I know but also I mean more
importantly and it's just some way of
saying thank you for me and
just giving people something to look
forward to I actually had a really a
strange moment on Friday night when when
the tickets went out and because they
literally just went online and they just
went in that second and a friend of mine
got a call from some people are actually
in the ICU saying we couldn't get the
tickets because we were on duty now can
we get some food we kind of through the
back door and they and so I said give me
their phone number so I facetimed them
while they're on duty in full PPE on the
ward and that really brought it home
just they were so excited even though
they could hardly hear me because the
phone even the phone had to be in a
plastic bag so it was all quite muffled
but just to literally talk to the
frontline felt that I was connected in
some way with the great job they're
doing the NHS all of us at some point in
our lives have an experience of the NHS
and I just wonder if it has a special
resonance with you every Thursday night
we turn up to to clap for carers you've
obviously given them this free party
this feel-good experience what does the
NHS mean to you norm what a few things I
mean my father is in an intensive care
unit for ten days couple years ago and
so I've spent a lot of time in there
seeing what they do so you know I've
been touched in that way avoiding
politics I've you know I've always been
a big fan of the NHS and always been
trying to be as vocal as possible in
helping the government to understand how
much we should be looking after the NHS
and you know basically financially so I
mean I won't you know if you're looking
for good news the good news is an awful
lot of politicians who maybe didn't
think the NHS was that important now
realise how important it can be in our
lives some of them very very directly
obviously you talked about your summer
changing this year it'd be first season
cancelled Glastonbury cancelled and this
party that you're throwing for NHS staff
won't be until October when do you think
we'll be gigging in the same way again
in terms of like you said what you do is
all about bringing people together and
it's gonna take a while for that to come
back isn't it naturally
mmm I mean obviously nobody knows but
one thing I'm pretty much sure of is
that the the shutters will come up very
slowly and in increments and I'm kind of
figuring that what I do is gonna be one
of the last things that's that's that's
allowed again in this appropriate again
so there you know so many other parts of
our lives will open up first and like I
said you know bringing tons of sweaty
people together in a very confined space
it's probably the most irresponsible
thing so it would be the last thing to
come back which just will make us
cherish it even more when that moment I
mean the sad thing is that they won't be
that that sort of VE Day moment oh you
girl go and dance in the streets because
it will happen so gradually probably
over six months I love a thought and
will be the last I think I mean I could
see myself probably if there's a limit
of like 500 people I should just be just
firing up every car that's got a fire
limit of 490 tomorrow night there's a
few there's a few venues in Brighton
that I've got of understanding with at
the minute that they're allowed to we're
just gonna put the party you know
whatever whatever level we can but I
think I think you know the the the big
international festivals are probably the
worst thing we could be doing right now
because people are travelling from all
over the world and then we're putting
them all squashing all together in a
very big unseemly pile so I'm not really
I mean at the moment I'm looking at half
my summer has been canceled so far and
this you know things like this as time
speaking camp bestival is still on but I
haven't really got my hopes on anything
large happening this summer well we know
you enjoy the intimate gigs as well so
that'll be good to ease you back into it
and also I don't know if you've seen
that picture doing the rounds on social
media norm of the first plane out to
Ibiza when eventually people are allowed
to return it is literally people hanging
off the wings and hanging out the
windows desperate to get back out there
and just you know have that feelgood
factor again yeah I mean there is plenty
to feel good over in the meantime I know
I thought I think what can best
did over the Easter weekend was great
especially for for us parents to get our
kids sort of somehow so just I know just
getting a virtual feeling of letting
your hair down and relaxing and
celebrating rather than the morning
oh yeah the kitchen disco is big right
now in lockdown it's big in my household
I know it's big in yours and because
like every good parent you're taking
your homeschooling very seriously but
different there you've got a DJ school
going a 10 year old Nelly your daughter
she gets top marks because this was her
performance the other week hi my name is
Nelly Cooke and from now on also known
as Farkas
so how did this all come about norm it
seems like music very much is the family
trade well then he's kind of been sort
of watching me DJ all her life and
thinking how hard can it be
mmm she so she's been kind of learning
them with me and then in the midst of
all I do every Friday night I do a look
down mix our fertile kitchen neighbors
but I've held off from doing the actual
kind of home gigs because watching a DJ
without an audience is kind of like
watching paint dry for me but then camp
bestival wanted to do a thing that got
all the kids up and they were doing a
big sleep out sleeping your guards
pretend you're a festival and they asked
all the people who are gonna be
appearing camp best of all to contribute
something and then I was just because I
was talking to my daughter Nellie and
camp festival this summer was going to
be her first ever festival and she's
gonna be so disappointed if it doesn't
happen and so I just thought it was a
way of getting her involved in camp
festival and I don't know I just I just
thought what if I get no need to dig
yeah and I'd help and would that be any
good and I didn't really didn't know if
he was gonna be any good at it and if
it's gonna be enjoyable for other people
if it's a bit self-indulgent but it was
it was fun for me nearly to do to set it
all up and do it work out a little set
for her and really caught the public's
imagination yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see who gets more
bookings when we come out of this on the
other side cos boy oh boy that was one
great debut set fabulous I mean sure I
was sorry she just stepped up to it like
should be doing all her life she had a
marriage proposal she's got various gig
bookings I mean that's she's had five
million streams and I thought the other
day five million people that's probably
more than I've ever deejay to my whole
career
traveling and late nights and just she
just strolls in it those 5 million them
on the first guy but now I'm very very
proud of that and I just I just felt
that is me using my talents to keep the
nation's morale buoyant in the best of
my capabilities I I don't know some some
things seem a little trivial time on
this and I mean for a while I thought
mean what I did was
you know if it looked like everybody was
doing you know DJing from their picture
nice like a point like this people don't
really want to watch you DJ in your
pigeon they've got bigger fish to fry
they've got kids to look after yes
well norm it's been so good to talk to
you I know you've got a pub quiz later
on
and my producer did say no I might be a
four or five minutes late for this chat
because he's having a shave so for those
who are watching on the video version of
this on YouTube you should be honored
those listening to the podcast you'll be
disappointed but now I know it's for the
pop quiz later on norm I don't know
about you see probably you you're still
in the public eye so you don't let
yourself go but certain standards I
thought is an audio podcast I know
you're not alone when I found out we
were doing a video version of this
podcast I was very disappointed nice
goodies kitchen on your toes but my
favorite quote from all of this is my
mum who cell phone she's quite old and
frail so she's self isolated week before
the lockdown and every time I say so how
you getting on she said well I've got
the garden you know she's got my husband
and she said she said he's quite nice
she said I don't have to feel I feel
like I have to make the effort because I
know no one's coming around norm thank
you so much for talking to us Norman
cook aka Fat Boy slim putting on that
party to end all parties for NHS staff
in October it's been great to chat and
stay safe night one you do to stay safe
stay sane haha since the lockdown so
many weddings have been postponed or
cancelled however many are still going
ahead in homes be congratulations to the
new mr. and mrs. struck and Julia and
Nigel who were going to get married in
London in June but they actually got
hitched this week on lockdown in their
back garden in Jersey with their
children present as Julia said love
always wins others have been saying I do
online with family and friends attending
on platforms like zoom
take for instance Harvey Skelton and
Hayley Pitman from Bristol there was
even the time on a tradition of a gay
crasher or be it a celebrity one may now
kiss the right
[Music]
[Applause]
special thank you from asset for better
for worse to sing your first dance song
we present Ellie Goulding so
congratulations Harvey and Haley and
your breakfast heroes and we all love
you and believe it or not some weddings
have been taking place at work on the
front line just like it did for sergeant
Murray McNulty and PCJ McGreevy they are
part of Greater Manchester Police is
berry division and they join me now
hello both congratulations thank you
thank you
now tell me what the original plan was
so the original plan was we've been
planning it for about ten months and
when we're going to get married in a
hotel called steak house sink it's been
with all our family and friends but
obviously due to the lockdown and that's
no longer possible so we've had to
postpone until next year and you were
working on what was meant to be your
wedding today a really busy time for the
police at the moment and but you
actually ended up getting married at
berry police station talk to me about
that how that came about Jay yeah it was
quite strange really because we were
looking forward so much to the big day
and then it's about to come to work what
would have been your wedding day not
really knowing what was going to happen
so then coming to work and get give him
a little car sash to wear I would end up
wearing around the division all day got
quite a few glances from members of the
public as well as colleagues icewine
weren't slowing on me body armor because
she had been talking to your boss about
this hadn't you because as it happened
your boss at Barry police station is
also a priest so you've been talking
about what you could do that day perhaps
to mark the occasion that was meant to
be your wedding day and it sort of
snowballed from there didn't it so talk
to me about what happens from the moment
you arrived at the station so
the day before I had sports mr. Finlay
who's an inspector but he's also an
ordained and weekend priest and and we
made the decision that we wanted to
still exchange our rings and what would
have been our wedding day so we kind of
asked him what he could possibly do so
he decided that he'd be able to bless
the Rings and do a small ceremony so he
went and got permission from the bishop
of Middleton and to be able to carry out
a small ceremony so when I came into
work the next morning the morning of our
wedding the girls in the office had
decorated all the office they were
playing here comes the bride as I walked
in and there was some champagne and
flowers waiting for us so obviously we
then went about and did our normal daily
work and then at the end of the day and
mr. Finn law do a little ceremony for us
and we managed to exchange airings Jay I
love this it's not quite the wedding you
imagined but how did it feel because you
know everybody when they think of
weddings thinks of big white dresses big
dinners discos bands all the hoopla that
goes with it but what did you actually
feel on the day must have been so
special it was it was lovely it was
really emotional mr. Finn lauded a
lovely service the girls brought me when
I walked in our Burson's tears in the
morning and I think the old think I'm
the big tough cooking series I just
showed my true colors there and but yeah
it was it was lovely it was emotional
it's not what we thought it was it was
very personal because there's a lot of
things going on in the world never mind
you know the come on over Harris that's
well known but to have to get on with a
bit of normality it felt very personal
to me because I got it in my head that
there's no way in the world that you get
married at this moment time there was no
way of doing anything like that and to
have something so personal from somebody
was offering so there was a service um
twice to feel like you it part of a
wedding service I got the nerves I've
got the jangling I got all that
well yeah but it was really nice to feel
I was you know doing something real
especial at a time when you know there's
a lot of uncertainty about well J I know
the the big party in the big celebration
with families and friends is on hold for
now you're hoping to do it this time
next year but after you had your
ceremony you had to get back on the
front line I just want to know what
that's like at the moment where you're
on the streets in Barre what's it like
being on the front line of this crisis
right now it's a very strange time you
know on for somebody to get used to this
for quite a while you know we've got
people unfortunately still having house
parties and completely you know ignoring
the lockdown rules
stay safe yeah there's a big part of
your job isn't it at the moment
educating the public on the need why
they have to stay home it's so difficult
for people at the moment with the
weather so nice and people's lives
changing but you're reminding why they
have to do that well Murray and Jay a
big thank you from all of us for the
work that you continue to do and a big
congratulations as well I know you're
gonna have to wait a while to celebrate
with family and friends but it sounds
like you had a really personal special
day and we wish you the best of luck for
the future
at your age now volunteering is big
during this crisis over 750,000 people
across Britain signed up to create the
national help service to provide support
to the NHS there are lots of schemes up
and down the country as well at a local
level that are helping the vulnerable
and isolated during the lockdown three
young brothers from Shropshire they
wanted to help the elderly in their
local area particularly if they're on
their own at the moment during lockdown
and their new project cheerful chat was
created but I'm delighted to say that
Johnny Tom and Ben first and join us now
hi boys well this is a wonderful project
you've set up it's an online chat
service for elderly people in your area
who came up with the idea well we we all
kind of did it together if you mean we
got it from calling our grandparents and
we just wondering how they work because
everyone's locked down you can't go
visit anyone and so we decided that we
just stopped calling people to see how
everyone
really yeah I love that so basically
you're adopting more grandparents that's
what you're doing kind of and Johnny
talked to me about who's getting in
touch with you and what'd you talk about
so it starts so we greet each other so
you say like hello how are you doing and
then basically just first on that so the
grandparents just say what they want to
say it's interesting isn't it Ben
because you might be the only people
they talk to all day how do you try and
cheer them up well we can't just like
talk about what they like and try and
just like how happy Jatin's and let them
say what they want to say and if they
like what you're saying like lunch then
or something
maybe you call them again Tom why did
you want to do this because you don't
have to do this she put your own
grandparents too chatty why did you feel
that you needed to set up cheerful chat
well we thought that so many people in
lockdown often live by themselves
especially maybe older people and they
don't have the best grasp of technology
so we decided to do because we really
wanted to make a change during this time
because so many other people are doing
such good things for any virus and so we
really want to tell power and so this is
our way of akkad yeah it's interesting
isn't it because you're so young I know
you want to volunteer but you can't go
out and do deliveries by yourself you
can't drive anyone anywhere so what you
can do is talk to people
Johnny and I just wonder you know what
are some of the funny stories that
you've told people or they've told you
what are some of the interesting chats
you've been having over the last few
days and weeks we've had some very
interesting ones for example one of our
earlier calls
talked about how someone who found
riding camels to elephants
it's Reacher I don't think they lived in
Shropshire but because we don't just
call it in shop shall we call roughly in
UK England yeah I'd love I'd love to
know what what one the camel or the
elephant um I think it was the camel
yeah I love that I love that you can
have fun frivolous chats it doesn't have
to be particularly serious he would win
a camel or an elephant it's brilliant
that you boys are doing
well boys you are brilliant chatterbox
is doing your bit thank you so much for
talking to us Johnny Tom and Ben thirst
and get to chat thank you
now a beautiful poem landed in our inbox
this week written by six year old
Tabitha Campbell from Henley in
Oxfordshire tatting as her family call
her shares her thoughts on the
coronavirus and her time with their
family on lockdown it is the sweetest
thing you'll hear today let's have a
listen coronavirus you're a funny old
thing
are you a blessing in disguise I really
miss my family and friends and you've
taken far too many lives coronavirus I'm
gonna tell you secret to me you've been
a lot of fun I've got to hang out with
my family and he ice cream in the Sun
well the poems all said tatty joins us
now alongside her dad and say hello both
hi hey dude yeah good thank you how are
you guys really good our attacks are
tatty we loved your poem here on in this
together
looking for the good and all the bad
stuff that's going on and I like the
question you asked is coronavirus a
blessing in disguise what do you think
there's good things and there's bad
things on there about the Cologne of us
what are the good things tasks that all
together we can play games we do play
alot of games we've got quite into cards
in this family so favorite card game
easy talk about the being the uno
champion sassy and what have you and
your sisters been doing what fun things
have you been getting up to
it's watching Kiki Mindy and do funny
things we've got a trampoline we just
put a trampoline in so that's that's
that's been a lot of them a lot of fun
hasn't it what other things have you
done what do you miss my friends because
no no Knox we get to see them you can
make me stand by
and I bet you're looking forward to
giving them all a big hug when this is
all over yeah yeah yeah I bet you are
and he talked to us and about what
you're saying to your children they're
three of them six four and two it's
interesting as a parent isn't it in
terms of how do you stop them from
feeling frightened or unsettled and keep
them positive when at times you know you
and your wife Katie must feel pretty
unsettled yeah I mean it is obviously
unsettling for everyone but actually I
think we've got to see this sometimes
through the eyes of the kids and for the
kids you know they've got their mom and
dad around them all the time so their
security blanket is really good at the
moment and you know ultimately we're
having a great time you know we're very
lucky that we've got a bit amount that
door space a garden and that makes a big
difference and the fact is is that you
know as a dad who loves these kids I get
to spend lunch and supper and breakfast
with them and see way more of them than
I ever ever would have done before and
you know what we've all been given the
gift of time right we haven't we weren't
asked for this gift but we've got it and
I'm pretty determined that we're gonna
make the most of it and I think we we
really are and that was part of the
reason that I started doing these Corona
Diaries because I kind of want to look
back at these times and remember the
positives and the good things about it
and I think that you know we're done
barded all the time with negativity
around coronavirus but actually you know
particularly from the kids point of view
I think there's a lot of good things and
you know the corona diaries from our
perspective our family perspective is
all about kind of sharing that with
other people because you know outside of
the kind of media bubble we get a lot of
good news stories which I know you're
focusing on on here with the podcast and
we just felt that was really important
to kind of spread really yeah as Tati's
poem said you're living through history
and you're documenting that as a family
in your coronavirus Diaries and we can
have a flavour now of what you've been
up to
Karuna
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
luckily did this start as a way of
keeping the kids occupied because as I
said there's six four and two home
schooling I'm sure there is some for the
eldest but it's not gonna give your day
as much structure as it is for other
families and obviously you can't go out
and about to keep them busy yeah
absolutely I mean I think initially it
was all about well for me actually as
quite a creative person I'll run a
creative agency so for me it was kind of
a way of keeping sane of doing these
videos because I was like what am I
gonna what am I gonna film what stories
that am I gonna tell for the next few
weeks few months few years and so so for
me it was really important to just see
what I had in front of me and tell
stories from that and actually that then
turned into something really positive
for the kids actually we've really
enjoyed putting little stories together
you know we've done challenges we've
done a music video we were caused on the
poem so you know it's it's about staying
upbeat and positive and keeping the kids
occupied as well because homeschooling
has its trials and tribulations I know
you take part in classic eras as a
family every week you're encouraging
people to go step further though aren't
you Antony and nominate their health
hero which i think is a lovely idea
I tell us more about it how can people
do this and as a family who's your
health hero um so first firstly my
health hero is my sister um Ali who's a
midwife at Lucian hospital and she's
doing amazing things during this period
of time and yeah The Clapper Care is an
amazing thing that we take part in as a
family every Thursday some real
highlight of the week and I know it is
for so many people but it's quite
generic right like we clap for all our
heroes whereas what I thought would be
really lovely would be to actually pick
people out personally that we all know
that are healthy rose in our lives and
so it was a movement that we started
with we cared for NHS which is their
their tag on Instagram and it's all
about kind of inspiring people to put a
message out there for their health eros
individually and flooding social media
with support for these amazing people
very much individually and the idea is
that we end up with this wall of
Timothy this wall of noise that is for
all the individual people that make up
our our NHS to say thank you to them
because you know wouldn't it be amazing
if at the end of this every single
health era in this country had a message
from someone saying thank you to them
individually that was out there that was
public Anthony is a lovely idea I'm sure
a lot of people will be getting in touch
nominating their health heroes it's been
great to talk to you thanks very much
goodbye to the Campbells
goodbye it's time for your good news now
hash tag in this together we welcome GP
dr. Zoe Williams she's back to share
your good news so many people getting in
touch over the last week in this
together at Skype don't you Kate's the
email address or you can get in touch on
social media at skyress Sarah Jane
hashtag in this together
Amy Witherington from pets pajamas dog
travel websites got in touch they're
using their Instagram page at the moment
to ask the country's dog owners to share
how their very best friends have been
helping them out keeping them sane
during lockdown and they're calling for
more people to join in you can upload
videos sending your messages using the
hashtag dogs at home and they've got
some celebrities involved as well Zoe
the likes of David Gandy he's got a very
cute little dog the presenter Laura
Whitmore and plenty of Made in Chelsea
stars as well let's take a look at one
of the videos hi everyone it's Laura
Whitmore and make us a dog Mick makes me
happy because he has to love me he has
no choice and can I find quite calming
and even though it's not always a
calming situation but it's lovely to
feel that much love from somebody he
gets excited everybody wake up in the
morning they're excited to see you and
that's nice because not everybody is
normally have you got any pet Zoe no dog
it seemed to mean it's this little dog
and he talks for Jordi axon and he's
always taking off for Paris because
they're saying they're just eating too
much and he's not getting in a walk I
saw a video from America Online the
other week of a pound and all the staff
were clapping because the pound was
empty because of lockdown
how many people have adopted pets or
given them foster homes during this
lockdown because people if they're
isolated on their own need a bit of
company right exactly but we must
remember doggies for life not just an
actor talk to me about Klatt for Kara
Zuri obviously this happens every
Thursday night I've been taking part I
hope you've been hearing it I hope it's
been encouraging you in the work that
you do this is a slightly different take
on it yes the Johnny Kathy from the doll
foundation so the doll is a drum is an
Indian drum so he's taking his London
Street when everyone is out there
clapping he's actually being playing for
his neighbors that's so brilliant I've
been thinking of ways to up my game it
was pots and pans last week and I was on
the Chris Evans breakfast show on virgin
this week and he said what about a
vuvuzela do you remember those from the
football World Cup the really noisy
instruments and I said NHS workers need
our support we don't need to add to
their stress with a feeling Taylor and
so I've still got a bit of time still
got a bit of time to think about how I
can up my game an NHS worker but I spoke
to so I'm gonna stop working at the
Nightingale we had our training last
week and it was one of the questions
that we were asked in our psychologist
session is how do you feel about this
collecting for carers and being named
heroes and I think for us on the
frontline we're just doing the same job
we've always done and it's sometimes
it's a little bit awkward so when I want
my four dogs them and I'm clapping and
I've muted recently and I'm almost
grateful that nobody knows I'm a doctor
because if they were sort merit like
what's me I think I just find it a bit
awkward that's the thing sorry everyone
in the NHS says it's just my job this is
what I do I don't want any thanks for it
but take it for goodness sake you
deserve our thanks and you deserve our
praise it's brilliant that you're so
modest about it
you deserve it Zoey don't be so modest
it's definitely not awkward for us just
really important for people as well that
sense of community because they're in
their own homes but once a week they
come out and they see that actually do
you know what we're all in this together
it's a really positive moment everyone's
got a big smile on their face and so I
think yeah it's incredible yeah let's
definitely keep doing it so I wanted to
tell you about there's a company called
little futures children's invites and
they make invites virtual advice and
parties and now they've given an option
for people who are purchasing these
invites to donate to the NHS so that can
give a percentage of a gift to the NHS
and the company themselves little
futures children's advice they'll waive
their fees and that directly to be an in
chest
appeal as well yeah that's really good
at it because all the kids are locked
down that having birthdays can't see
their friends and it's not just kids
Zoey I know that it was your old 40th
recently and I got a very special invite
to come to your birthday party online
yeah it was one of my friends she she
has the zoom subscription so you can
have up to 100 people so I managed to
arrange for got one to be deejaying via
Instagram live and for everyone to be on
my TV screen and I used to play rugby at
uni and the would be girls
old habits very hard I was shaking
champagne and every time I talked with
my glass ok exactly and you haven't got
too far to stumble to bed after the
party's over
adults and kids enjoying parties online
because of course we can top me up with
our friends at the moment but good on
that company for donating a fee to help
kids get together online enjoy their
birthdays and raise a bit of money for
good causes in the process
and we were talking earlier about
weddings and so many of them postponed
and canceled but some still going ahead
for those of you love live music you
might have heard of the function band
now there are show band there's around
20 of them that perform they often
perform at celebrity parties and they
were recently performing before lockdown
at the 30th birthday party have Billy
fares from The Only Way Is Essex where
they were hugely popular in demand band
and their founder Zoey he is Dan Rosen
he got in touch with this message we're
so grateful for the amazing work that
the NHS are doing and putting their
lives at risk so we wanted to give
something back if we could so we thought
we'd run a free competition for one
lucky NHS worker to win the function
band performing at their wedding and to
enter you just head over to instagram
our handle is at the function band and
look at our latest post and just comment
on that with your Instagram handle or
your friend or family member and that's
it it's so good luck and get taken right
finally to play us out Zoe this is
brilliant this is the showcase music
school you've got in touch with us
online to say that they've set up
virtually so they are now the virtual
Youth Orchestra they're all under 18 and
they've been doing their own renditions
of a lot of famous pieces of music
including a piece of music you might
recognise this is the showcase music
school the virtual Youth Orchestra with
their rendition of the sky nice theme
tune that's going to play us out this
week Zoe
it's been really good to see you and
speak to you thank you so much and keep
up the good work on the front line thank
you having made thank you for keeping us
all sane and entertaining it and yeah
this piece music was just amazing
[Music]
you